-Hey, guys, right now it's time
to look at these stories
making headlines today, and
weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
-♪ Pros and cons
and pros and cons and pros ♪
-Now, tonight
we'll be taking a look
at the pros and the cons
of being the Batman.
-Ooh.
-It's the number-one movie
right now
everyone is talking about.
Let's look at the pros and cons
of being the Batman.
Here we go.
Pro -- hearing people say,
"Whoa, it's Batman!"
[ Laughter ]
Con -- having to correct them
by saying, "Um, actually,
it's 'The Batman'?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
No big deal.
Pro -- responding
to the Bat Signal.
Con -- realizing
this could have been a Zoom.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Could have been.
Pro -- Colin Farrell
spent eight hours
putting on makeup
to play The Penguin.
Con -- Robert Pattinson
just walked into a Sephora
and said, "Go nuts."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Healthy guy.
-Uh, pro -- winning
against the Riddler.
Con -- failing
against the Wordler.
Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I didn't know it was a villain.
Was it?
-Wow. Wordle?
-Pro -- wearing the Batman mask.
Con -- spending 45 minutes
trying to get
your iPhone Face ID
to recognize you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- saving the world
one day the a time.
Con -- not being able
to brag about it on Instagram.
It's like, "So, this happened."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- saying, "I am vengeance.
I am the night."
Con -- hearing the
Starbucks barista say, "Okay,
either way, your
caramel macchiato is ready.
So, night, vengeance, whatever.
Take it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- defeating The Joker.
Con -- having to face
his henchmen,
The Smoker and
The Midnight Toker.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on.
Some people call him
The Space Cowboy, too.
-A little Steve Miller reference
right there.
-Some people call him Maurice.
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
-And finally, pro --
see the Bat Signal
shining across the sky.
Con -- getting a text message
from Commissioner Gordon
5 seconds later
that says, "U up?"
There you have it.
Those are the pros and cons.